Easter is the celebration of Jesus'
victory over death, his resurrection
from the dead. Many world leaders mark
the occasion by wishing Christians a
happy Easter. But if we know anything
about British leaders, it's that they're
going to use this Christian holiday to
tell us about Islam, even though the
vast majority of Muslims believe that
Jesus never died and never rose from the
dead. So, how is King Charles going to
inject Islam into a Christian holiday
celebrating an event that Muslims
reject? Let's find out. There are three
virtues that the world still needs.
Faith, hope, and love. And the greatest
of these is
love. He's quoting First Corinthians 13,
which is an amazing chapter of the
Bible. It's sometimes called the love
chapter. King Charles says that the
world needs these three virtues: faith,
hope, and love. I agree
completely. Can you think of three
virtues the world doesn't need? I can.
Stupidity, gullibility, and cowardice,
mainly because they're not really
virtues. They're only virtues according
to British leaders. But let's see how
the king works Islam into his Easter
message. One of the puzzles of our
humanity is how we are capable of both
great cruelty and great kindness.
Indeed, kindness towards the grooming
gangs and cruelty towards their victims.
This paradox of human life runs through
the Easter story and in the scenes that
daily come before our eyes. At one
moment, terrible images of human
suffering and in another heroic acts in
war torn countries where humanitarians
of every kind risk their own lives to
protect the lives of others. A few weeks
ago, I met many such people at a
reception in Buckingham Palace and felt
a profound sense of admiration for their
resilience, courage, and compassion.
Strange. The king praises the heroic
acts of people who risk their lives to
protect others. And yet, the British
government throws people in jail for
criticizing an ideology that calls for
the violent
subjugation of their
children. On Monday, Thursday, Jesus
knelt and washed the feet of many of
those who would abandon him. His humble
action was a token of his love that knew
no bounds or boundaries and is central
to Christian belief. He says that Jesus
love knew no bounds or boundaries. So
that when he brings up Islam in the next
sentence, Christians will think that
this boundless love means embracing an
ideology that calls for the violent
subjugation of Christians everywhere.
The love he showed when he walked the
earth reflected the Jewish ethic of
caring for the stranger and those in
need.
Pause. Why does King Charles mention the
Jewish ethic of caring for the stranger
and those in need? This Jewish ethic has
way more to do with Jesus than Islam
does since Jesus lived, died, and rose
from the dead in first century Israel.
But why mention it here?
I would be totally fine with him
mentioning it if I didn't know that he's
just manipulating his readers. King
Charles has no interest whatsoever in
referencing Jewish ethics in a message
about Easter. He only brings up Jewish
ethics so that when he inserts Islam
into the discussion, the agenda won't be
as conspicuous. In other words, if he
randomly tossed Islam into his Easter
message, his intent would be glaringly
obvious. But if he mentions Jewish
ethics first, followed by Islam and then
other religious traditions, he's just
being broad-minded and reing in
diversity. With that in mind, the love
he showed when he walked the earth
reflected the Jewish ethic of caring for
the stranger and those in need. A deep
human instinct echoed in Islam and other
religious traditions and in the hearts
of all who seek the good of
others. Now that he's fulfilled his
kingly duty of praising Islam, he can
finally say something about Easter.
The abiding message of Easter is that
God so loved the world, the whole world,
that he sent his son to live among us,
to show us how to love one another, and
to lay down his own life for others in a
love that proved stronger than death.
There are three virtues that the world
still needs: faith, hope, and love. And
the greatest of these is love. It is
with these timeless truths in my mind
and my heart that I wish you all a
blessed and peaceful
Easter. I wouldn't ordinarily have much
to say about Islam in an Easter message,
but since King Charles brought it up,
I'll just mention four verses from the
Quran. Surah 5:51.
Oh you who believe, take not the Jews
and the Christians as aliyah, friends,
protectors, helpers. They are but aliyah
of each other. And if any amongst you
takes them as aliyah, then surely he is
one of them. Verily Allah guides not
those people who are the zalamoon,
polytheists and wrongdoers and unjust.
So don't take Jews or Christians as
friends, protectors, or helpers. If you
do, you're a Jew or a Christian, not a
Muslim. Surah 9 verse 29. Fight against
those who believe not in Allah, nor in
the last day, nor forbid that which has
been forbidden by Allah and his
messenger Muhammad, and those who
acknowledge not the religion of truth,
i.e. Islam among the people of the
scripture, Jews and Christians, until
they pay the Jiza with willing
submission and feel themselves
subdued. So Allah commands his followers
to fight us until we pay tribute money
called Jiza with willing submission and
feel ourselves
subdued. What's Jiza? Here's the
commentary.
Paying Jiza is a sign of kufur unbelief
and disgrace. Allah said until they pay
the jiza if they do not choose to
embrace Islam with willing submission in
defeat and subservience and feel
themselves subdued, disgraced,
humiliated and
belittled. That's what Allah commands in
surah 9 29. What did Jews and Christians
do to deserve such treatment? Next
verse. And the Jews say Usuzair Ezra is
the son of Allah. And the Christians say
Messiah is the son of Allah. That is
their saying with their mouths
resembling the saying of those who
disbelieved a four time. Allah's curse
be on them. How they are deluded away
from the truth. So, Jews have to be
subjugated because they claim that Ezra
is the son of Allah. Even though Jews
don't claim that Ezra is the son of
Allah. Christians have to be subjugated
because we claim that Jesus, the
Messiah, is the son of Allah. Allah
curses us for calling Jesus the son. Why
is this relevant? Well, King Charles
said, "The abiding message of Easter is
that God so loved the world, the whole
world, that he sent his son to live
among us." Since King Charles just
called Jesus the son, the Quran says
that Allah's curse is on King Charles
and that he must be violently
subjugated. Although in this case,
violence may not be necessary since the
king seems all too willing to bend the
knee. And if the abiding message of
Easter is about Jesus, the son of God,
then Allah's curse is on Easter. Strange
to praise a religion that curses Easter
in a message about Easter, but that's
British leadership for you. One more.
Surah 98:6.
Verily those who disbelieve in the
religion of Islam, the Quran and Prophet
Muhammad from among the people of the
scripture, Jews and Christians and al-
Mushrakun. Mushrakun are people who
associate partners with Allah will abide
in the fire of hell. They are the worst
of
creatures. According to the Quran, Jews
and Christians are the worst of
creatures. We're lower than dogs. We're
lower than pigs. were lower than
insects. If you ever wondered how the
grooming gangs could justify treating
non-Muslim girls so horribly, it's
because they view non-Muslim girls as
lower than dogs, lower than pigs, lower
than insects. It's straight from the
Quran. Part of being a good king or a
good prime minister is acknowledging and
confronting harsh realities.
Unfortunately, the UK has King Charles
and Kier Starmer, aka Dumb and Dumber,
weak and weaker, fake and faker. But for
those of you who think that with such
pathetic leadership, the United Kingdom
is officially doomed, think again. Jesus
followers thought he was gone until he
appeared to them more powerful than
before. I invite all of you in the UK
who are mourning the death of your
culture to turn to the one who conquered
death. I speak from experience here. I
had completely ruined my life by the
time I was 20 years old. I was in a jail
cell waiting to be sent to my third
mental hospital waiting to be sentenced
for another crime. when I realized that
if anyone knows how to deal with a
hopeless
situation, it's the one who rose from
the dead. And here I am almost 30 years
later wishing
you happy Easter.
[Music]